Щиро вітаємо вас у програмі У фокусі
Європа далеко від війни в Україні а в
Європі розгортається чергова драма на
шляху через море продовжують гинути
мігранти з Африки лише цього року у
відкритому морі загинули або безслідно
зникли сотні людей при спробі досягти
своєї мріяної мети потрапити до Європи
Попри це більшість мігрантів усе ще
наважуються на переправу у переповнених
часто непридатних для плавання човнах
з Африки до Євросоюзу можна потрапити
також із сухопутним шляхом однак він є
не менш небезпечним про що свідчить
трагедія у мелілії іспанський екс-клав у
Північній Африці безпосередньо межує з
Марокко при спробі добратися звідти до
мелілії в червні загинули десятки
мігрантів свідком цих жорстоких сцен
став А трум із судану кількість людей що
які він намагається втекти до Європи
ризикуючи при цьому своїм життям буде
зростати оскільки через війну в Україні
багатьом країнам Африки загрожує голод
24 червня під прикордонним парканом біля
мелільї марокканський прикордонники
жорстоко б'ють сотні африканців як
показують зйомки очевидців
перед цим мігранти намагались масово
штурмувати кордон Марокко і з Іспанією
в результаті загинуло щонайменше 27
африканців десятки поліцейських отримали
поранення
суданець а трун сам був свідком цих
подій
він уже 10 разів намагався потрапити до
Європи і таку катастрофу ніколи не міг
собі навіть уявити
вони просто почали нас бити і сказали що
це останнє попередження
ви самі бачите більшість людей тут ще
мають тілесні ушкодження
Вони ж не завдали їх самі собі
вони продовжували нас бити на і тоді
коли ми вже лежали на землі
і припинили лише тоді коли ми втратили
свідомість і більше не могли рухатися
тим часом атрон знайшов спальне місце у
покинутій школі у касабланці
Марокканські сили безпеки кинули його та
інших суданців тут за сотні кілометрів
від кордону
однак катрун серйозно звинувачує також і
іспанських поліцейських
він уже був на європейській території
щоб подати там заяву про захист біженців
але сили безпеки його примусово
депортували
людей назад до марокканців
або ж їх забирає з їхнього дозволу
марокканська поліція
більшість вважає що перетнувши кордон
вони вже досягли мети Але часто їх
просто знову депортують
по той бік кордону у мелільї все бачив
місцевий журналіст Хав'єр ангосту
іспанський чиновники говорить він
намагалися перекрити дороги до
прикордонної території
Репортер показує нам як він зміг пройти
навпростець і підтверджує розповідь
суданця
Я бачив На власні очі як 30-40 мігрантам
вдалося перетнути кордон
але потім їх знову депортували жоден не
отримав шанс подати заяву про надання
притулку
дія Яка порушує міжнародне право
більшість мігрантів прибули із судану і
чаду країн жителі яких мають хороші
перспективи отримати притулок
Ми беремо інтерв'ю у голови
регіонального уряду висуваємо йому
звинувачення
можливо був той чи інший випадок
тут буває стільки спроб перетнути кордон
що ми всі переживаємо
війна подорожчання зерна продовольчі
кризи усе це має помітні наслідки
ми Лілія місто з населенням майже 90
тисяч осіб є одним із небагатьох
європейських міст яке має прямий
сухопутний кордон і з африкою люди
постійно намагаються перелізти через
12-кілометровий паркан ті кому це
вдається зазвичай прямують до міського
центрального пункту прийому
але за високими мурами нам знімати
заборонено говорити на камеру також не
хоче жоден мігрант
для місцевого журналіста ангосту не
зрозуміло чому трагедія 24 червня досі
не мала політичних наслідків
марок просто робить за нас брудну роботу
адже ми хочемо і надалі залишатися
Яскравим прикладом у справах прав людини
глава регіонального уряду лілії також
критично розцінює співпрацю з Марокко
але не бачить жодних порушень з боку
Іспанії
варто лише подивитися ці жорстокі записи
все це ніколи не повинно було трапитися
але це сталося Не на іспанському боці а
На американському це допустили
марокканців тепер їм доводиться
виправдовуватися також і перед своїми
африканськими сусідами вони повинні
взяти на себе відповідальність
усі ці події не відлякали мігранта
атруна Після повернення з Марокко для
нього залишається лише одна мета
подолати прикордонний паркан мелілії
я Буду намагатися знову і знову Нам
нічого втрачати
що дані немає можливості вільно
розвиватися навіть якщо ти здобув світу
єдиний вибір піти в армію Або шукати
нелегальну роботу
а трун та інші намагаються звести кінці
з кінцями завдяки продуктам харчування
які пожертвували Сусіди і вистояти Поки
вони зрештою не доберуться до Європи
да
до Європи та до Європейського Союзу
хочуть також і бажано якомога швидше
більшість грузинів бо їхня країна як і
Україна на яку напали є сусідкою Росії
Тут також тліє конфлікти навколо
сепаратистських регіонів південної
осесії та Абхазії багато грузинів
бояться стати наступної мішенню Путіна
молода активістка Марія ґеґучадзе робить
усе що підготувати шлях своєї країни до
ЄС але це кам’яниста дорога
так Європі десятки тисяч грузинів
марширують столицею Тбілісі після
відмови ЄС надати їхній країні
перспективу членства
вони звинувачують у цьому власний уряд і
вимагають його відставки
[оплески]
у центрі подій Маріам гегу чадзе для неї
Європа це більше ніж географічна
близькість до заходу
[музика]
для неї Європа це майбутнє
і боротьба за це справа всього життя
Я вважаю що Грузія заслуговує бути
гордим членом ЄС але я також знаю що на
цьому шляху Є багато проблем тому я
роблю все можливе щоб це змінити Я живу
заради цих змін
[музика]
Однією з проблем є сусідка Грузії Росія
каже Маріам ґучадзе
з нею Ми їдемо туди де ця проблема
особливо помітна на кордон із
сепаратистською Республікою Південна
Осетія
за міжнародним правом цей регіон на
Кавказі належить до Грузії
але впродовж трьох десятиліть його
контролює Російський уряд у Москві
з російськими грошима і російськими
військовими які розташовані у Південній
Осетії і яких люди бояться саме зараз
після нападу Росії на Україну
через дві з половиною години Ми на місці
село кедуетті прямо на кордоні з
південною осетією
місцеві люди скаржаться на те що цей
кордон постійно зміщується
вони кажуть що російські війська
окуповують дедалі більше території
Грузії
У деяких садибах межа проходить навіть
посередині городів
Я боюся росіян
російська армія на відстані всього 5
кілометрів
хоча в моє село ще не заходив жоден
російський солдат ми все одно маємо
постійний страх
особливо після того як росіяни вторглися
в Україну
центральний уряд тут Тбілісі мабуть
також боїться конфлікту з Росією і олією
проявляти нейтралітет
хоча Грузія офіційно засудила війну але
вона не бере участі у західних санкціях
проти Кремля
натомість керівництво у Тбілісі нападає
на власних критиків зокрема протестний
рух ганьба членом якого є Маріам гегу
чадза
відповідальність за відмову ЄС надати
Грузії статус кандидата на вступ ганьба
покладає над Тбілісі а не на Брюссель
вони звинувачують свій уряд у тому що
той робить недостатньо з огляду на
сусідню Росію
але уряд різко відбивається
ці люди хочуть щоб нашу країну охопила
хвиля масових протестів і заворушень і
щоб усе закінчилося війною з Росією це
їхній план але ми цього не допустимо
їхня пропагандистська машина діє якщо
придивитись то Можна помітити що вони
використовують ті ж самі методи що й
Росії
тут багато хто не виключає що російський
президент Путін не зупиниться після
війни в Україні і одного дня нападе
також і на Грузію адже Грузія теж була
частиною Радянського Союзу які очевидно
як бояться вони Росія хоче відновити
Єдина країна яка перешкоджала розвитку
Грузії яка знищила грузинську культуру
традиції та релігію це Росія
і саме тому ЄС мав би надіслати сигнал
Росії і дати їхній країні шанс на вступ
вважають Маріам та її соратники
відповідно розчарування через ніс
брюсселя було великим
Це був один із найсумніших днів у моєму
житті
взагалі В глибині душі є оптимістка
тож мала крихітну надію на диво
[музика]
проте дива не сталося але вони хочуть
продовжувати боротьбу
допоки Грузія не стане членом ЄС
[музика]
продовжити боротьбу ходжу італійка Марія
Тереза імператор за те щоб люди в її
рідному місті Неаполі мали перспективу
передусім діти бо чим далі на південній
талії тим більший вплив мафій
в Неаполі - це камора яка є всюди в
багатьох районах особливо в бідних
зокрема сам Джованні а тедучо саме тут
Марія Тереза імператор та її соратники
ефективно протидіють організованій
злочинності як саме це пов'язано з
енергією з великою кількістю хорошої
енергії
[музика]
бідний район Сан Джованні А ти дудчого
на схід від Неаполя мешканці називають
бронксом
Цей район символізує бідність безробіття
та мафію але саме тут почалася
енергетична трансформація Неаполя
парно почати звідси адже ми хочемо
соціально справедливого енергетичного
переходу
Ми повинні разом боротися зі зміною
клімату та соціальної несправедливістю і
ось що ми тут зробили
на даху цієї будівлі було створено перше
енергетичне товариство Італії 166
сонячних панелей виробляють
електроенергію для 40 сімей так енергія
стала частиною соціального проекту
оскільки колишній дитячий будинок фонду
фамілія Ді Марія є координаційним
центром для сімей місцем де дітей
забирають з вулиці щоб вони не стали
публічними каморе Але в цьому є певні
ризики
це діра від кулі випущена і перед входом
до фонду
вона втілила в цю стіну явно ознака
організованої злочинності одна із
великих проблем
вона хоче показати що такі місця
небажані бо ми виховуємо дітей на повазі
до закону
наша зброя - це книги музичні
інструменти а також сонячні панелі
дженара 11 років він щодня приходить у
фонд тут він став екологічним активістом
адже діти відіграють у цьому
енергетичному проекті важливу роль саме
вони вмовили батьків взяти в ньому
участь
ось тут ми встановили більше сонячних
панелей також навпроти і на цьому боці
це мене тішить оскільки принаймні ми
щось робимо для клімату
мамі Я сказав що це добре для
навколишнього середовища але ще так
можна економити гроші
поскладали чірілу працює У фонді 20
років але для нього це набагато більше
ніж альтернативний генератор
електроенергії
Ми намагаємося запропонувати цим дітям
альтернативу шанс ми їм кажемо Гаразд це
складний район Тут є багато огидних
речей але є також і щось красиве місце
де можна займатися театром і музикою де
є люди які будуть тебе слухати які
можуть тобі допомогти тут у тебе є шанс
щоб пограти у настільний футбол взяти
участь в екологічних майстер-класах або
позайматись музикою сюди щодня приходить
понад 100 дітей як улітку так і взимку
покажу що ти можеш
ти суперзірка
електрики полягало в спробі подати
сім'ям знак Подивіться перше енергетичне
товариство було створено не в центрі
міста а тут на сході наполя
нарешті на першому місці що впливає на
мешканців і вони більше не вважають себе
останніми забутими хто завжди отримує
лише рештки ні Цього разу ми перші
установка коштувала 100 тисяч євро її
профінансував фонд зараз сім’ї є
дрібними підприємцями у галузі
енергетики Вони не тільки самі
споживають електроенергію але й продають
її тепер уже кілька місяців поспіль їхня
установка біля підніжжя везувії виробляє
зелену електроенергію
[музика]
це енергетичне товариство представляє
новий напрямок для цього міського району
багато екологічних проблем досі не
вирішені багато соціальних проблем
залишаються Мафія все що присутня але
нарешті тут є і позитивна історія
історія
яка набула популярності за їхнім зразком
у всій південній Італії з’являться
впродовж наступних кількох місяців
десятки нових енергетичних товариств
що переживають зараз люди в Туреччині
якій вимушені витрачати багато грошей
навіть на хліб та інші основні продукти
харчування за все що необхідне їм для
життя туркам доводиться платити в
середньому майже на 80% більше ціни
підвищує в першу чергу слабка валюта А
як щодо президента
ердогана турецький економісти критикують
його за те що для стримування інфляції
він робить занадто мало в той час як
сім'ї все відчайдушніше намагаються
зводити кінці з кінцями
що купуєте ви Коли йдете в аптеку
можливо не те що ви бачите за моєю
спиною але кілька сотень років тому
такого скорпіона вважали лікувальним
засобом і не тільки його якщо ви зараз
подорожуєте Північною Європою все ще
шукає то особливу мету у столиці Естонії
Італії а ви можете поринути у світ
чудодійних ліків а давніх часів
опудало крокодила у часи Середньовіччя
обов'язково для кожної поважної аптеки
оскільки усе екзотичне вважалося тоді
ліками Саме так ратушна аптека в Талліні
заохочувала своїх клієнтів у будівлі
навпроти ратуші із 1422 року безперервно
продають ліки
а в сусідньому музеї берги таларніц
пояснює туристами Сталіна та сарима що
тоді продавали із прилавка
раніше підпалювали голки їжака тоді
вважали що дим від голок їжака очищує
аурубудинку і захищає від хвороб тобто
своєрідні їжакові ароматичні палички і
як дізнається сім'я використовували
також сечу їжака як учні краплі
Ну я не дуже хочу чи є із сечі у своїх
очах
під стелею розвішували висушених жаб щоб
Чума не заходила в дім а олія із дощових
черв'яків мала зміцнювати імунітет у
підвалі музею берліта пояснює ще одну
розумну стратегію продажу тодішнього
аптекаря щойно покупець заходив до
аптеки він пропонував йому Міцне червоне
вино зі спеціями це підіймало настрій і
розв'язувало язик
клієнт розповідав про те що його
непокоїть і поступово в нього з'являлось
бажання купувати
Смакуй як портвейн або як глінтвейн
якщо ви не дуже обізнані із маззю гадюки
та кров'ю кажанів то сучасні ліки
доступні в торговому залі поруч із
музеєм в ратушній аптеці талліна досі
можна купити старовинний лікувальний
засіб марципан
марципан покращує настрій і полегшує
любовну Тулу а При розумному дозуванні
він також абсолютно не шкідливий
тут років концентрованих фармацевтичних
знань у Талліні Вони залишаються живими
щодо марципана то я за нарешті ліки які
приємно смакують Бажаємо вам успішного
тижня і Дякуємо за перегляд нашої
програми У фокусі Європи до наступної
зустрічі
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив переклад Володимира та Олесі
Швед режисер Павло Тимченко текст читали
Олена потоцька Юрій Лисенко та Олесь
гоян Київ 2022 рік